♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
FIRST IT WAS A CRISIS, THAT IT
WASN'T, THEN IT WAS.
WHAT COULD IT BE NOW?
>> THIS PRESIDENT JUST USE THE
BACKDROP OF THE OVAL OFFICE TO
MANUFACTURE A CRISIS.
SPEAKER RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> SOME QUESTION IF THERE IS A
CRISIS AT ALL.
>> WE DO HAVE A CRISIS OF THE
BORDER.
>> AND INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL
TELLS CNN "NO ONE IS SAYING THIS
IS A CRISIS EXCEPT THEM."
>> START NEGOTIATING IN THIS
BORDER SECURITY CRISIS?
>> NO SIGN OF THE NATIONAL
EMERGENCY THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S PRETTY TRANQUIL.
>> Greg: CRISIS, NO CRISIS,
CRISIS.
THE MEDIA IS LIKE YOUR DUMB
FRIEND YOU ASKED TO STEP OUT OF
THE CAR TO SEE IF THE BLINKERS
ARE WORKING.
YEAH, WORKING.
NOT WORKING.
WORKING.
HOW CAN YOU MAKE SENSE OF THIS?
JOURNALISM IS JUST ANOTHER FORM
OF HYSTERIA.
A CYNICAL PERSON MIGHT THINK OF
THE PRESS CAN'T BE IN THE CRISIS
ON YOU THAN THE CRISIS DOESN'T
EXIST.
MEANWHILE WE SEE THE CRISIS WITH
OUR OWN EYES.
WE SEE THAT COYOTES AS PEOPLE
WHO TRAFFIC IN SUFFERING.
THE MEDIA SEES THEM AS GOOFY,
COLORFUL TOUR GUIDES.
A RESULT OF CHILDISH DENIAL THAT
WILL MAKE YOU SAY ANYTHING OTHER
THAN THE TRUTH.
STUFF THAT BORDERS ON THE
OBSCENE.
THE BORDER CRISIS IS A LONG-TERM
PROBLEM THAT MAKES PROBLEM
SOLVERS IN THE SHORT TERM LOOK
LIKE THE BAD GUYS.
THE PARENT THREATENING TO TAKE
AWAY THE KIDS AVOCADOS.
MEANWHILE THE DEMS AND MEDIA
DON'T KNOW WHAT A CRISIS HAS.
THEY ARE LIKE A SAILOR SAYING
HIS LEAKING BOAT WORKS GREAT
UNTIL IT'S IN THE WATER.
THAT'S HOW THEY SEE THE BORDER.
IT WORKS JUST FINE.
UNTIL SOMEONE IS CROSSING IT.
THEN YOU HAVE THOUSANDS GRASSY
DAILY IN THE MEDIA REVERTS WITH
USUAL AMNESIA.
IT'S A CRISIS AGAIN, EVERYONE.
SPEAK OF THIS MIGRANT SITUATION
IS CALLED A CRISIS.
THAT WORD IS OVERUSED.
IT DOESN'T DO THE SITUATION
JUSTICE.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE.
IT'S NOT EASY TO SEE.
LET'S SHINE A LIGHT ON IT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
LET'S GET AFTER IT.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
FOR TWO YEARS THEY WERE
SCREAMING THAT WE HAD A RUSSIAN
PLANT IN THE WHITE HOUSE NEVER
CONTEMPLATING THE EFFECTS.
SMARTER PEOPLE KEPT THEM FROM
DESTROYING THE COUNTRY AS THEY
DESTROY THEIR OWN CREDIBILITY.
THE FAILED MEDIA TRYING TO TELL
YOU WHAT MATTERS.
KENNEDY, A CHILD'S VIEW IS
SOMETHING BAD IS HAPPENING NOW.
LET'S FIX IT.
AN ADULT VIEW IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW HAPPEN BEFORE AND
CAN HAPPEN LATER, SO WE NEED A
LONG-TERM FIX.
ISN'T THAT WHAT THIS IS REALLY
ALL ABOUT?
>> Kennedy: THAT'S A GOOD WAY
OF FRAMING IT AND KING VERSUS
THE -- CONGRESS IS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE ADULT, THE BODY THAT
LOOKS AT LONG-TERM EFFECTS OF
IMMIGRATION AND PERHAPS
ALLOWING PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
WHO WANT TO WORK AND HELP OUR
ECONOMY AND WHO WANT TO FILL
SOME OF THE LABOR SPOTS THAT ARE
IN CREDIBLY TIGHT.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS VERY, VERY LOW.
WE DO NEED HELP FROM OUR FRIENDS
FROM THE SOUTH FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA AND MEXICO.
HAVING SAID THAT, WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN LIMBO, THEY
ARE TORN BETWEEN TWO COUNTRIES.
THEY WANT TO GO TO THE LAND OF
THE FREE, THEY WANT TO GO TO
AMERICA AND HELP THEIR FAMILIES
AND ESCAPE PLACES RUN BY DRUG
CARTELS BUT THEY CANCELED THE
RUSH FOR THE EXITS JUST LIKE IF
YOU ARE IN A CONCERT HALL AND IT
CATCHES ON FIRE COMING OR GOING
TO HAVE A STAMPEDE AND PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO GET HURT AND THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
CONGRESS IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
BODY THAT MAKE SURE THERE ARE
FIRE CODES AND FIRE
EXTINGUISHERS AND PLENTY OF
EXITS SO PEOPLE AREN'T TRAMPLED.
>> Greg: EXCELLENT ANALOGY.
>> Kennedy: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: JESSE, I BELIEVE SHE
MAY HAVE DONE A BETTER ANALOGY
THAN YOUR HORSE ONE FROM LAST
WEEK.
>> Jesse: YOU STILL
REMEMBERED.
>> Greg: SHOULD THE DEMS
REALIZE YOU CAN'T CREATE A
COUNTRY OF GREAT FREE STUFF
WITHOUT A CONTAINER THAT HOLDS
THE FREE STUFF.
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT A BORDER IS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT, GREG.
THIS IS ABOUT DEMOCRATS WANTING
TO TURN TEXAS BLUE.
IF TEXAS IS BLUE, REPUBLICANS
WILL NEVER WIN ANOTHER
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
YOU WON'T EVEN HAVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
IT'S OVER.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION
FOR THE BORDER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO SOLUTION.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
ONLY A FEW OF THEM WILL SAY
THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE POLITICAL
COURAGE.
THEY WILL HIDE BEHIND THINGS
LIKE IT'S NOT A CRISIS.
LET'S GET SOME MORE BEDS FOR THE
DETAINEES.
NOT TRUE.
HAVE THEY EVEN GONE DOWN TO GET
A BRIEFING FROM THE BORDER
PATROL?
HAVE THEY EVER EVEN GONE TO
MEXICO OR CENTRAL AMERICA TO
TALK TO THEIR COUNTERPARTS
QUESTION OR DO THEY WANT TO
CHANGE THE DETENTION POLICY, THE
ASYLUM POLICY, THE CATCH AND
RELEASE POLICY?
NO.
WE HAVE LISTENED A VIDEO ON
THEIR SHOW BORDER PATROL AGENT
SAYING IT'S LIKE THE
UNITED NATIONS WE ARE CATCHING
CROSSING.
ALBANIANS, PAKISTANIS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS, MS-13,
GANG BANGERS.
THEY ARE BRINGING CHILDREN WHO
THEY DON'T KNOW WITH THEM TO
CROSS THE BORDER BECAUSE THE
MINUTE THEY CROSS AND SET FOOT,
WE HAVE TO CATCH AND RELEASE
THEM AND SAY IN TWO YEARS WE'LL
SEE WHAT THE IMMIGRATION HEARING
BUT THEY DON'T SHOW UP.
THAT'S NOT A COUNTRY.
THAT'S A LAWLESS NATION.
>> Greg: JUAN, DO YOU AGREE,
I'M SURE YOU DO.
TURNING TEXAS BLUE.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHY YOU CAN'T
SOLVE A PROBLEM.
PEOPLE SAY OFF-THE-WALL THINGS
AND YOU HAVE GANG BANGERS AND
MURDERERS AND TERRORISTS FROM
SOUTHEAST ASIA.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
>> Jesse: NO GANG BANGERS ARE
ACROSS THE SOUTHERN BORDER?
>> Juan: THIS WAS LIKE TRUMP
YESTERDAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IF I CLOSE THE
BORDER, NO IMPACT.
MITCH MCCONNELL AND THE
REPUBLICANS HAD TO TELL HIM
MR. PRESIDENT, EVEN THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE HAD TO TELL HIM
MR. PRESIDENT, IT'S GOING TO
DAMAGE THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
DON'T DO IT, STUPID.
HE GOES OFF AND HE SAYS PEOPLE
FLYING FOR ASYLUM, ONLY 3% SHOW
UP FOR THE HEARING.
MR. PRESIDENT, IT'S CLOSER TO
90%.
SO HE DOES THINGS, LIKE SEPARATE
KIDS FROM FAMILIES.
OBAMA HAD UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
THESE ARE FAMILIES.
WHEN HE USES THE TERM CRISIS, HE
USES THINGS LIKE WE ARE BEING
INVADED.
THIS IS AN INVASION.
IT'S A MILITARY -- NO, WHAT
YOU'VE GOT IS WHAT KENNEDY
DESCRIBED.
FAMILIES WHO SAY YOU KNOW IT,
IT'S GETTING HARDER WITH THIS
GUYS RHETORIC, SO WERE GOING TO
TRY TO PUT OUR CHILDREN IN
BETTER POSITION TO HAVE ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY.
WE WOULD LIKE TO COME.
MAYBE WE SHOULD GO NOW BECAUSE
TRUMP'S RHETORIC IS SO DIVISIVE.
>> Greg: WHAT?
LET ME GET DANA IN.
DO YOU BELIEVE IT'S TRUMP'S
DIVISIVE RHETORIC ENTICING
PEOPLE FROM CENTRAL AMERICA?
>> Dana: IS YOUR POINT THAT
HIS THREAT TO CLOSE ON THE
BORDER --
>> Juan: THE WHOLE THING.
I THINK IT DOES SEND A MESSAGE
TO PEOPLE IF YOU'RE COMING, YOU
BETTER GO NOW.
>> Dana: WE'LL SEE IF THAT
HAPPENS.
WE KNOW IT HAPPENED WITH OBAMA.
I CAN'T REMEMBER WHAT THE
DECISION WAS PUT YOU HAVE THESE
MIGRANTS COMING BECAUSE THEY
WERE LIKE OH, MY GOSH,
SOMETHING'S GOING TO CHANGE.
>> Greg: YOU COULD ARGUE THE
OPPOSITE.
>> Dana: SURE.
TO YOUR ORIGINAL POINT ABOUT THE
ADULTS, THE ISSUE REALLY IS LAWS
AND POOR DECISION.
THE LAW BEING THE ASYLUM PIECE,
THE COURT SCISSION BEING THE ONE
THAT YOU CAN'T HOLD CHILDREN FOR
LONGER THAN 20 DAYS.
LET'S SAY IT'S TRUE THAT 90%
SHOW UP FOR THEIR HEARINGS BUT
IF A MILLION PEOPLE ARE COMING
IN THE YEAR OR MORE.
100,000 IN MARCH, IT STARTS TO
GET, THAT'S A PRETTY BIG NUMBER
AND THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
NUMBERS WITH HISPANICS IS ON THE
RISE.
WHY'S THAT?
THEY DON'T LIKE THIS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO HELP
THEM IN TEXAS, THE DEMOCRATS IN
TEXAS OR ARIZONA OR ANYWHERE
ELSE.
>> Kennedy: EVERY LATINO
PERSON IS GOING TO AUTOMATICALLY
VOTE DEMOCRAT?
>> Dana: IT'S NOT TRUE.
HE DOESN'T HAPPEN.